mesdames messieurs bonsoir roland garros
en bas âge c'est sans parapluie les
internationaux de france avait repris
aujourd'hui un air de fête
tout est maintenant en place pour les
grandes finales au terme d'une journée
qui a confirmé que les meilleurs sur le
papier était aussi les meilleurs sur le
terrain
mcenroe et lendl tête de série numéro 1
et 2 se retrouveront pour la finale
messieurs tandis que chez les dames
martina navratilova et chris evert lloyd
se retrouveront elles aussi pour le
dernier tour et puis une surprise enfin
presque surprise yannick noah jouera en
finale mais il n'y a pas de miracle là
dessous puisque c'est dans le double qui
s'est qualifié en compagnie d'henri
leconte le compte rendu de cette journée
avec gérard holtz et roger zabel en
commençant par les quatre balles de
match difficile d'ivan lendl
lendl a gagné les deux premiers sets 6 3
6 3 il mène 6 5 dans le troisième
première balle de match
le sauvetage de vilander wilander
attaque sur la ligne lendl renvoie mal
volées gagnantes devine rien sauvé pour
la première fois deuxième balle de match
le doute lendl toujours au service
première balle trop longue faute
deuxième balle dans le filet ou le faute
aïe aïe aïe troisième balle de match
l'impatience lendl sert trop impulsif
son coup droit sort
quatrième balle de match merci la ligne
lendl serre sur la ligne volée de coup
droit sur la ligne
wilander traque lendl game où il se
qualifie pour la finale
bon ben maintenant je vais aller
regarder le match
connors mcenroe pour voir la façon dont
il joue c'est certain il y aura pas de
surprise mcenroe va monter au filet au
noir ce va essayer de retourner le mieux
possible
ce sont deux très bons joueurs alors peu
importe qui gagne ce sera il a vu mais
il a aussi entendu ivan lendl jimmy
connors à john mcenroe qui vient de
discuter une décision de l'arbitré alors
il coûte
j'en ai marre que tu te comportes comme
un gamin tu as vraiment l'âge mental de
mon fils tu as compris oui brett le fils
de jimmy connors a aujourd'hui cinq ans
mais son père à 7 ans de plus que john
mcenroe et jimmy connors ce ne va
pouvoir résister que l'espace d'un set
le premier après il sera opposé à un
bombardier qui va passer 49 % de
premières balles de service et 12e au
total
john mcenroe a gagné quatre jeux blancs
pour se qualifier pour la première fois
de sa carrière pour la finale de roland
garros le score 7-5 6-1 6-2 et pour le
plaisir le plus beau point de ce match
ivan lendl a bien raison de dire que ce
sera difficile dimanche cet homme est
vraiment dangereux